Reggie Miller NBA on TNT reg has Game
two between the Rockets in Warriors
that'll be coming up tomorrow night and
then he'll be in Houston for Game four
that'll be next Monday reg joins us now
reg where do you want to start with this
series with between Golden State in
Houston well here's the thing if if the
Rockets would have won that ballgame I'm
sure we would have heard the same
comments about having a fair chance
coming from Kevin Durant klay Thompson
and Steve Kerr and the Warriors and
Steph Curry so look it's in the eye of
the beholder where the officiating bad
absolutely but they were bad on both
sides and here's the problem Dan you and
I have had this these conversations on
this very show numerous times and this
is the conversation I had with the
league so what you're telling me and
this is a conversation I have with the
league that you're gonna call this in
October November December all this
freedom of movement
the shooters being able to come down in
one spot you know guys going underneath
him and they did October November
a little bit in December they called it
freedom of movement no clutch e no
grabbing they called all that well as
you and I know come playoff time players
decide games in the game becomes much
more physical it becomes much more
half-court no more freedom of movement
no more up and down and running it
becomes half-court sets and your best
defense versus some best offense which
we're kind of seeing in this series
because we have great one-on-one players
Kevin Durant James Harden Steph Curry
great one-on-one players so all this
clutching grabbing that were thousand
october/november to see December when
there was freedom of movement and they
absolutely called it and there was no
hand checking the game becomes much more
physical come playoff and officials like
to swallow their whistle they want the
players and teams to decide games is it
right no but I had this very
conversation so
you're telling me Monty McCutchen is
you're going to call that in April of
May and his response was absolutely we
have to so look the league if they have
to decide how they want to do this all
right
because personally I like how it's being
officiating because you're letting
players decide but you called this all
year long so why not call it in the
playoffs but how can you change though
reg can you change the philosophy of
what you're gonna call from game to game
in this series it and here's the problem
it will change it will change on Tuesday
because it would be a different
officiating crew and it's in the eye of
the beholder
so these officials they let it put they
were led to play rough they were letting
Ally go you might have another
officiating crew tomorrow the game that
Kevin Harlan and I are calling that
everything will be a touch foul it's I
the beholder so it could very well
change but if the Rockets would have won
that game we overheard the same comments
coming from the Warriors so in my
opinion the officials did a great job
because it was that yeah but I can't say
well it's bad on both sides therefore
it's fair it shouldn't be bad on both
sides and I and I have a problem with
the the Warriors putting that foot
underneath James Harden when they try to
close out on Harden I just don't like
that reg because you know if you went up
for a shot and I put my foot underneath
you you're thinking about coming down
and trying to avoid my foot and I
thought they did that a couple of times
with James Harden let's go back to where
this rule came from and this came from
in that very building when Zaza Pachulia
you contested on Kawhi Leonard when San
Antonio was up by 22 points in the first
half comes down twists his ankle and has
done the rest of that series they lose
that game which they had in full control
and that's really where this rule came
from I'm not going to sit here and say
the the Warriors are doing that
purposely because they're closing up
Howie if you do not close out two
shooters if you do not contest if you're
not close
to a shooter I don't care who you are
these guys are so talented it's easy
money so you've got to be able to
contest you've got to be someone close
to a shooter
I'm not saying purposely come down and
put your foot underneath where someone
could twist their ankle that's a dirty
play what Zaza did was a dirty play if
it was intentional I can't I can't get
into the head of Zaza but if you're
doing it intentionally to hurt someone
absolutely but it's hard for the
officials to deem is he doing this on
purpose or is he closing out James
Harden creates a lot of space from his
contacts there's a lot of times he's
throwing chicken wings to create space
as well and they're not calling it
people need to look at it at both sides
here because I look me of all people
I will never come to the defense of
officials I love officials they're all
great guys but it's so hard to officiate
James Harden because he travels he
creates space from his chicken wings and
he wants to foul when they're coming
underneath him but he doesn't want them
to call it when he's creating space with
his off arm on that step back it goes
both ways people yeah you're the
Godfather of that kind of getting your
leg out there and drones in contact are
you well I got it from world be free
that's where I first started like seeing
like oh my goodness he's creating space
with that little leg kick so in my
backyard Riverside California I kind of
started shooting kind of like that when
defenders were close to me it was great
until Doc Rivers and coaches started to
say wait a minute this is an illegal
move and then it got banned I mean like
I would say half of my four-point plays
were because of that of me creating
space with my legs it's not my fault
you're that close to me back off do you
realize that James Harden that he was
fouled 101 times shooting three-pointers
this year that's
a 1/3 2/3 the next on the list is 36 so
he's got 101 granite he takes more
threes than anybody but he does get
those calls and he does create
separation and I and what I agree with
you I think it evened out that it was
just bad I can't have bad officiating in
a game of this magnitude even if it's
bad for both sides yes absolutely
everything you just said is correct
there there's blame on both of the
officiating was bad but it was bad for
the Warriors and it was bad for the
Rockets we would be here in these same
comments from the Warriors if they had
lost that ballgame and how many of those
potential three-point fouls that James
Harden got you said 100 and something
did he get in Game one did he get even
one probably not so that lets you know
how bad the officiating was and yet he
was fouled by the letter of the law and
what they're talking about freedom of
movement and players being able to calm
down on their jump shot what they called
in October November December January yes
he got fouled but what they are calling
in the playoffs and letting the players
decide and being more physical that it's
I had to be holder this officiating crew
let it be an old-school late 90s early
2000 playoff game that's what it was
they let the players decide and it was
much more physical he's ready to change
tomorrow he's Reggie Miller the
hall-of-famer he's got tomorrow night's
Game two between the rockets and
warriors at 10:30 Eastern on TNT
McLovin has a high I'm gonna say this
then if anything the Warriors are
kicking themselves I'm excuse me the
rocket home they sure won that game I'm
saying absolutely should've won Game one
you've had short rest for the Warriors
to get there two of their main three
guys have not severe
you know sprained ankles but they're
gimpy they're not running as they Nomar
doing klay Thompson and Steph Curry this
is a game you had to have this is a game
you should have won by double digits
going away Mick like Kevin Durant
McLovin Isaiah Kevin Durant
take care okay Reggie when they give
Kevin around a good matchup like a guard
covers him I feel like the words have to
go to Durant and it becomes one-on-one
ball and takes them out of the kind of
basketball they want to play and sort of
screws them up they hit a bunch of twos
and the Rockets get the advantage
because they can hit threes that crazy
no it's not crazy but it depends on what
the matchup is and like I highlighted
earlier come playoff basketball the game
slows down anyway so all that motion
offense and freedom movement and ball
movement and high assists that we see
the Warriors get during the regular
season that's all great and things but
when you get into a playoff series and
Mike D'Antoni and his staff is taking
away two or three of the Warriors best
offensive weapons and plays and you've
got two players that are somewhat gimpy
on bad ankles you've got to feed Kevin
Durant so I don't mind the isolation
one-on-one but the Rockets have to make
threes if they're going to give up those
mid-range twos - Kevin Durant who has
been unbelievable him and Kline Leonard
have been unbelievable in these playoffs
in terms of offense so the way KD is
going I don't mind that if I'm Steve
Kerr because because if you're gonna put
a guard on him he's gonna get any shot
he wants but you've got to counteract
that by making threes they didn't make
enough threes in Game one to counteract
the mid-range game of Kevin Durant
I like how we are somehow concerned that
Kevin Durant may not be all-in with
Golden State meanwhile he's probably
played his best basketball in the last
five weeks and it feels like the other
but like the other guys on the Golden
State Warriors are the ones leaving in
free agency not Kevin Durant the other
words need to be saying thank you thank
you Katie because he is absolutely
carrying them but I will say this this
is what makes them special because
before it was the defense of draymond
Green it was the shooting of klay
Thompson and the overall play making and
shooting of Steph Curry
Katie adds a different wrinkle to them
because he is the best one-on-one player
probably in the game right now along
with James Harden so he just
as a different dimension to them and
when he has a cooking like this
especially the playoffs and the game is
slower you could just throw him down
there who are you gonna put on him PJ
Tucker he's physical but he's only six
five he can shoot over them you're gonna
put a small guy like Chris Paul on them
okay that's lunch meat there's there's
note that you're trying to put a bigger
player in a switch and Clint capela
all right I'm right by you and I'm
finishing at the rim there is no one who
can guard KD in this series and we saw a
little bit of this in that clipper
series when he was challenged by Patrick
Beverley and you know who I am you guys
don't know I am and he showed out okay
well we're seeing the best of Kevin
Durant right now I'd still love that
I'm Kevin Durant you know like who are
you have fun tomorrow night there Reggie
in Houston and you might be like the
fifth or sixth best three-point shooter
on the floor tomorrow night you're
absolutely right about that and there's
no shame in that I would say maybe the
third okay maybe fourth
okay so clay instead is there anybody
over 50 in the world
I'll put James in there James James
better three-point shooter than you
James Harden a better three-point
shooter okay but it's closed the door is
there any okay if the entire world 50
and over had a three-point shooting
contest man give me the give me my belt
is there any former player that you
would worry about who's over the age of
50 from three-point range Craig Hodges I
would worry about a Glen Rice I don't
know if he's 40 though I may worry I
don't know if he's gonna be 50 you said
over 50 over 50 I would say Craig Hodges
that's the only guy yes Glen right
is 51 I would worry I would worry about
the wind I would worry about Glenn
what if bird got in shape shape well you
have to get there Glenn Robinson and
Gudrun risin I'm not going there
he's the one that carried them and also
a weekend though in shape or not do you
mean Ray's not 50 so well out the way 50
yeah alright well just in case you know
that comes up in conversation we can
start a tournament with 50 and over if
they can do this three on three good
luck tomorrow all right
that's Reggie Aloysius Miller junior the
third for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on VR live or download
the Dan Patrick show at